donc je suis le local de la soirée est
donc effectivement c'est commencer la
trompette à l'harmonie bâle doit quand
j'avais une porte on essaye t c'était
vraiment un signal conduit toute ma vie
encore maintenant parce que cet
instrument là je l'adorent jeunes
adorent depuis tout petit et donc des
qui réussit à avoir ce qu'on fait c'est
fini elle est en outre commencé à
baisser
je jouais le matin à jouer avant d'aller
à l'école je dois bien qu'elle soit
j'avais trouvé en fait ils le sont mais
le timbre donc évidemment après le nom
disney a commencé à plonger plonger et
donc uni c'est des garçons tels
comportements sens
et donc évidemment on rentre en
terminale mon père me dit qu'est ce que
tu dois faire plus tard donc évidemment
je n'y réponds jouer de la trompette
ce n'était pas vraiment prévu cependant
en plus office unnim d'émigrés italiens
tout ça la réussite sociale il connaît
très bien parce qu'on estime et donc
comme j'étais bon à l'école surtout en
libye il procèdera à devenir un
saltimbanque tout se crée dans les
turpitudes équilibre misérablement
famille bout de tuyau est donc là je me
dis ça va mal se passer
en plus la majorité à 21 ans vont pas
l'aider
9 il faut qu'ils trouvent une solution
où on arrivait
donc allez trop tôt nomme c'est pouvoir
joue de la trompette
déjà l'on en prend du temps donc là j'ai
eu la chance de la musique la musique de
l'herbe de bison de la base de dijon
la première liaison aérienne est nu
faire un concert ça une cérémonie
militaire ici avec toi moi je déçu donc
j'ai séché les cours et je suis à des
déboires et cela réduit est ce que je
peux faire mais service militaire je
suis maudit aucun problème
tu viens à dijon et puis tu bien par sa
vie pendant la plus tordue
mon père ne vaudra jamais dijon passer
un examen de musique leur ai dit je
mettais ma trompette
je peux passer l'examen maintenant là et
donc recettes de musique ni sarthe orne
où il montre les deux minettes maison
quant à elle mais deux bus sur la place
d'armes
il n'y a pas d'endroit quoi même si on
voulait on ne pouvait pas de carpates et
annick pamart
on commence à discuter intérêts versés
et moi je vous dis car sa bande mus et
finalement vous accepte donc ils mettent
dans la travée du milieu du bus et ils
se mettent autour comme sur mon gsm fil
des morceaux des morceaux de militaires
donc je suis dans tout ça ils sont aux
anges
on a besoin de toi donc c'est sûr tu
peux venir faire ton service avec nos
cellules donc là déjà je me dis ça y est
c'est une porte de sortie
parce qu'enfin de champion ne s'est pas
d'autres je ne connaissais aucun
musicien professionnel à part les
musiciens du bal dans la région avec
jeannette réussit une pommeraie les
parades complètement
donc il fallait absolument que j'aille
ailleurs et que je puisse être
tranquille pour jouer batman
donc voilà donc j'ai rater mon bac c
avec maestria et donc j ai mon
commentaire était tellement tellement
étonné je me dis oui mais tu sais pas je
peux aller faire mon salaire après leur
premier titre
pourquoi ces moments tellement reste au
bal des maudits
donc voilà donc j'ai bossé quelques mois
a gangsta pour me faire un peu d'argent
pour l'heure un mystère
je suis allé dans cette musique
militaire adjoint et là bas donc à un
concours pour moi je fais pendant que je
faisais mon service mais bien sûr c'est
que je m'accompagne s'est pas beaucoup 1
6 heures par jour et où il faut il faut
soutenir et en fait j'en ai profité
là-bas pour tout recommencer un terreau
avec donval conservatoire aventure qu il
ya trois mois
parce que l'on sonde ne plaisait pas
donc que le tavana travail génial mais
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas mon monde
sont à moi il ya des choses qui
n'allaient pas et comme jamais a pris
plus ou moins quand même un petit peu
pour seule et même chose que j'avais pas
compris sur vos fonctionnement d'apple
donc j'ai fait un an donc avec un
professeur noppen délai court masculin
et on l'attend recommencer à zéro
et pendant que j'étais à l'armée donc
j'avais le temps de travailler j'avais
donné à tout le monde mais fut moins
tranquille et donc j'ai eu mon prix à la
fin d'année mais à partir de là j'ai
commencé à travailler tout seul sur
vraiment mon sont sur le son je voulais
moi je voulais entendre et qui n'est pas
à son de trompette
vraiment je suis allé un petit peu
contre le côté projection du son de la
trompette afin que les sites et ma
petite affaire à moi à cette même
période
je m'aperçois que dit il à faire un
concert à la manip en tout
donc j ai
et là ils ont une heure de retard tout
public commence à ronce coco et donc
avec 10 semaines tout seul sur scène est
pas complète
il commence à parler en américain là je
m'aperçois que des gens qui comprennent
valent pas et dont l'hôtel voilà elles
commencent à appeler devant tétouan et
puisqu'il comprend pas trop fait une
frappe qui commence vendredi
[Musique]
nous allemands
absolument pour moi je peux pas de faire
part et je puis rencontre cet homme là
les dames du terme sur un hugo qui
n'habitait pas même noir je savais pas
où avec deux fortement gens n'ont pas
les moyens d'aller d'aller le retrouver
donc ce n'est pas cette partie des
choses possibles et donc voilà donc je
fais des standards mais tout ça je
rencontre une finition satin massa au
bout de sept ans on se dirige l'harmonie
droite je viens propre on parlera donc
ça en fait une vraie situation quoi
donc c'est bien mes parents sont très
contents donc tout va bien et qu'ils
aiment mais moi je veux me ne l'a pas
mal pas réussi à gagner sa vie en jouant
de la comptable c'est déjà pas mal
et pendant que tu prends la baronne
évidemment un concert est organisé avec
il dit
alors là l'espoir renaît dans la moi je
n'écoute que ça un peu disent que je
travaille tout l'est m
les morceaux qu'il a écrit enfin tout ça
je me prépare comme je parle toujours
pas l'enlever
les images de sonic at the job il ya un
angle en dedans tu dis tu viens avec moi
ont beau dire le jour du concert à deux
heures de l'après midi
on était près tout seul et donc mon
anglais quand même pour un peu noir pour
lui quoi parce qu'on a attendu jusqu'à
20 heures
et à cinq heures de musiciens pour
arriver mais le 110
donc les grands ministères on rate
rarement mon piano enturbannés vraiment
clair et donc qui font le sont dans
cette fois mais il n'ya pas d'oubli
[Musique]
sorte à transat et puis toujours un peu
plus bas depuis une balle vole
ça passe ou ça casse je ne fais tu
commences ont joué la garde non
et puis il se passera rien un petit côté
il continuer à jouer et puis moi aussi
donc on fait des morceaux de 10 juin
d'asile tunisiens je pense à moi je joue
avec eux depuis le bas et puis je range
mon agent ils s'en vont donc mon anglais
toujours là et des recettes ready la
ligne et puis taille alors la venue et
des gens ont une idée côté draka matin
moi j'aime bien mon anglais on y va on
se met une chemin
bon on arrête tout ça il dit comprendre
que cette première compétition que
j'écoutais quand j'étais jeune machin
[Musique]
diop et vitaly lopota mon anglais lui
raconte tout ça alors je ne sais pas
trop comment enfin machin
et puis tizi notamment l'une ou l'autre
des rires et tout ça et puis voilà et
par ce changement va derrière le concert
commence
et moi j'ai exclu sur le côté de la
scène la scène est comme ça moi je suis
le petit etienne et chapeau d'enfants
le concert pendant entre nos doigts
cheminera je m'appelle pas c'est tout le
contraire
absolument qu'ils ont crié je pense plus
à rien - embarqué par le menu la seconde
batterie le pacte commissoire pied le
nom de nick
sinon sur une enceinte
et dynamique la façon dont on devine
donc tout près de moi voir des jeunes
footeux solo de batterie
et grâce une coup mais à l'aube de
manager et coller avec moi qu'on est
déjà me et donc moi je n'ai pas su
saisir leur garde et il me dit je pense
tunisie le savoir et donc elle qui
travaillent ici
il a joué avec nous commente péter pas
mal mais tous âges qui pas moins
changeable la bataille est finie ce
marteau qui était la femme du mental in
fine ce morceau est dit devant les amis
et maintenant je vous présente les
meilleurs compétiteurs on est
convalescent et à dia alors la semapa ne
peut pas sortir tout ça mais je chante
mon but l'embouchure de la troupe le ans
plus tard mais on a mis son grain par
trouve à côté de baby ptin liberia
bagarre au sourire
une sorte on est tu fais un cap et une
fois un tel affront du ballon et une
rente le même effort
misty le tabou du jour bonjour il va
derrière c'est donc là moi je suis à bhl
10 secondes après le 10 à côté de moi et
l'affaissement on se marre à faire des
plats de pâtes on joue ensemble et on a
complètement impossible maintenant
impossible donc évidemment moi j'étais
crash ont toute mon énergie en 7 minutes
mais il en importe là
[Rires]
la jolie bon y'a plein de choses encore
à apprendre à gérer ça mais bon après le
concert tout se passe bien il m'invite à
boucler un mélo le lendemain on la mange
me promène dans one à ancenis états unis
[Musique]
mais donc après ce moment là comme s'il
avait atteint vraiment quelque chose de
beaucoup trop donc à 13 h et une espèce
de petite dépression parce que je
voulais plus de combattre la chaîne de
tri est arrivé à un niveau entre at il
écrit à la terre et donc la plus un sale
moment comment tu peux faire est donc là
parce que tu viens entendre j'étais un
contrat en bretagne
monsieur tapé l'avant par une voiture
nombre de bateaux donc été immobilisé
pendant six mois
et là je commence à m'emmerder sur le
second point est donc au bout de trois
mois dans le titre ou autre chose dont
j'ai repris ma trompette
j'ai toujours travaillé c'est con quand
j'ai remarqué je reçois donc j'avais
recul désir ajoute combattre mais en
jouant cette notion de tout à fait
différent de ce nouveau divisé qui était
dans un bel exemple pour moi donc j'ai
commencé à chercher un peu lent et loire
et à rencontrer d'autres musiciens dont
un collectif de musiciens à lyon où là
c'était vraiment du cru que j'avais
assez libre fort
et ça ça m'a vraiment intéressé
donc j'ai fait partie et puis après
voilà je rencontrais division au
département de monde et donc je me suis
aperçu que en fait
mason forme de santé s'était trouvé ma
musique à moi pas seulement bon son mais
aussi le contenu parce que moi pour moi
la musique c'est vraiment comprenait
tout
comprenez ce groupe de légende mais joue
avec eux mais jouable mais n'importe où
n'importe quand sauf que je réagis sept
jours par rapport aux autres et que
j'avais pas on n'est pas du tout
réfléchi à cette histoire mais en amour
chacun en donc voilà
et donc maintenant on en arrive là
à
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
aïe
m
[Musique]
ans